what are the differences and outcomes
for kids growing up in a single parent
versus a two parent
household so we can we can start by
seeing that in the immediate term let me
let me emphasize some like basic things
if a kid only lives in a household with
you know a one parent or an unmarried
mother which is mostly the case there's
a f you know there chance of living in
poverty are five times higher part of
that reflects the fact that you know
moms from low-income backgrounds are
more likely to become single moms but
even if you just look across moms of the
same level of Education same background
characteristics it's not surprising that
kids from Married parent households live
in households with more income okay
income is a big part of the reason why
these kids do better why because their
parents can spend more on housing in
better neighborhoods they get access to
better schools we see that you know
these parents spend more on their kids
and enriching activities and educational
activities they basically have more
opportunities you can see this in the
most you know simple way like it's
really expensive to play for Co pay for
club sports or music lessons so kids
from Mary parent homes have different
opportunities it translates into better
outcomes they are less likely to get in
trouble in school and let's come back to
that finding because that's a really
interesting one they're less likely to
get in trouble in school for boys in
particular they're less likely to get
suspended part of this comes from the
fact
that you know here I'm drawing on
development psychology when when boys
are sort of suffering internally they're
more likely to act out and what
psychologists refer to as externalizing
Behavior girls are more likely to
internalize it so I don't want to see
that girls are necessarily not
struggling as much but boys are more
likely to act out which means they're
more likely to get in trouble in school
and they're more likely to get suspended
and that Cascades then we also see that
they're more likely to be involved with
the criminal justice system so it's just
again getting back to like the idea of
oh let's stop pretending like two
parents are
beneficial there's no way to look at the
data and the studies and not feel like
oh wow kids from gar homes are much less
likely to get in trouble in school
they're much less likely to get in
suspended they're much more likely to be
engaged in crime they're more likely to
graduate high school they're more likely
to graduate college they're more likely
to have higher earnings as an adult
they're more likely to be married as an
adult less likely to be a single parent
themselves this is again why this is so
crucial for us to address because we are
by allowing this class divide in family
structure to continue it's accentuating
inequality it's undermining so it's
undermining social Mobility because
there are both short and immediate term
effects in childhood they have lasting
effects on sort of someone's lifetime
trajectory and then these compound
across the generations have you been
able to analyze whether the children of
single parent households are more likely
to become the parents of single parent
households that is something that lots
of people have documented that's well
established so you also you almost have
this kind of recursive feedback loop
that makes it ever more common 100% And
also to get back to the conversation we
were having about like what's up with
men that so many of them either don't
view themselves as somebody who should
commit to a family or the women don't
view them as somebody who's worth
committing to as a family we actually
there's a there's there's a lot of
really well done studies from the past
10 years showing that boys are
particularly disadvantaged by the
absence of a dad from their home
okay some careful work done by um The
Economist Marian berran and Jessica
Capon tries to get at why that is like
what what's driving that in the
household the interesting thing that
their research uncovers and again this
is using really large scale nationally
representative data sets is that boys
get less investment parental input
nurturing parenting they're more likely
to you know have their mom spank them or
be harsh to them again that's not me
judging single moms it's really tiring
to parent it's really hard to maintain
your temper when a kid is misbehaving if
especially if it's a boisterous boy
especially if it's a boisterous boy and
you don't have someone else to be like
could you could you take over I need a
break right so we just see they see in
the data in these data sets that record
like do you spank your kid what how
connected do you feel with your kid how
much time do you spend with your kid you
see that boys from single mother homes
get less of that but what's really
interesting is that boys are
particularly responsive to that so let's
say the differences in the parental
inputs or Investments are small how they
respond to that is large right another
way to think about this is I have a
daughter and a son if I you know sort of
ignore my daughter whatever she's
probably not going to go to school and
get in trouble if I am like harsh with
my son if I don't put in as much time in
him if he's really struggling he more
likely to go to school and get in
trouble right like that sort of what
he's missing in parenting is more likely
to lead him to act out in a way that
gets him suspended and then all the
snowball effects so boys are
particularly disadvantaged by not having
a dad in the home and you know how that
affects them there's another study that
came out of the opportunity insights Lab
at Harvard this is the lab run by Raj
chedy and colleagues that has you know
access to millions of tax records so
they know exactly where kids grew up and
then they follow them into
adulthood the single biggest
predictor of whether a black boy sort of
climbs the economic Ladder into
adulthood
at a neighborhood level so what
neighborhood characteristics are most
predictive of economically good outcomes
for black boys can I guess go ahead the
proportion of single fathers the
presence of black dads in the
neighborhood y so beyond just having a
dad in your house if you have if there's
a bunch of you know if the households
around you black households around you
also have dads single biggest predictor
of whether you do well economically in
adulthood and and so there again who's
being helped by us
denying that black boys in particular as
if like all of the Discrimination we
know they face all of these other
barriers like those boys are are being
harmed by not having dads around and so
this gets back to the intergenerational
nature of
this the more boys we have growing up
without dads in their
house the less likely they are to sort
of Thrive and be their best eles when
they grow up which means the less
capable they're going to be to be
supportive reliable married dads and
again this is just like we've got to
break this cycle yeah it's this
uh oroborus of like
ineligibility and
irresponsibility and that then creates
another generation that creates another
generation that creates another
generation so have you read anim the the
life of Dad no this is something
something that you should absolutely
read so she's an evolutionary
Anthropologist she came out of Robin
dunbar's Lab at Oxford and um I just had
her on the show I'll send you the
episode you can listen to great um and
she talks about the importance of
fatherhood um from from a a
developmental perspective and she looks
at it through an anthropological lens
she looks evolutionarily does some
evolutionary pychology one of the really
interesting things that she folded in
and you're right um Ruff and Tumble play
especially for boys especially in early
uh childhood is very important because
it teaches them the role of fathers is
largely to both play but to set rules um
that you can climb that tree but you
know you can't you like go don't go
higher than that as opposed to Mom would
have not let them go up the tree at all
and this uh understanding allowing of
risk-taking behavior a little bit more
is good now the interesting thing the
really interesting thing I learned from
her that I think you would love to fold
into some of your work is what happened
to adolescent girls without a father
yeah now when you get into teenage years
it is absolutely crucial that a
adolescent girl has father around when
the boys are there a little bit more
that it seems like their acting out
Behavior it's more crucial for the boys
earlier on but for the girls it seems to
be during that that later period and you
get like all sorts of weird
sociosexual nudges yeah here and there
you get all sorts of Strange Behaviors I
know like Daddy Issues is kind of meme
but it it almost seems to have Arisen in
the data you know this is like a really
sappy thing for me to say and I again
like to be clear all of the conclusions
I draw in the book from very rigorous
analytic work with data but this was
really sort of salient and top of Mind
recently because of course I think about
all this and I'm thinking all the time
about the class gaps in this and how how
can we not be honest about this and I
was at a graduation dinner my son just
graduated at high school and so there
were a bunch of families there and
almost every dad that got up to toast
his boy also toasted his wife everyone
in this room was married okay and and
would say things like and these boys are
great boys because they have strong moms
and there was and I was
like what an example this sets to both
our teenage boys and our girls right
this is what you should expect when you
grow up you you like celebrate your wife
and you treat her well and girls this is
what you should expect right and so
again it's just sappy but it I was like
this is such a perfect microcosm of this
privileged class of kids getting exposed
to this positive example um which is
just not nearly as widespread or
prevalent and also by the way when you
read the interviews with like these
unmarried couples who go to some of
these you know not well-funded
um programs in the communities that work
for strengthening families and so you
know social scientist and I used to be
one of them sort of poo pooed the bush
initiatives that like healthy marriage
initiatives because like doesn't even
increase marriage but then when you read
the interviews with the folks they keep
showing up to these relationship classes
and they say things like you know I
didn't come from a two parent family I
don't really might you know I don't
really know that many married people
they don't have an example of how to
make it work right um so it's it's again
this these anecdotes all sort of confirm
what we see as Trends in the data every
single morning for over three years now
I have started my day the exact same way
which is with element in water element
contains a science-backed electrolyte
ratio of sodium potassium and magnesium
and it is the best hydration drink that
I've ever found it tastes fantastic it's
super refreshing orange is just the most
OP flavor in the world it's absolutely
phenomenal and it helps to play a
critical role in reducing muscle cramps
and fatigue it regulates your appetite
it optimizes brain health and it helps
curb Cravings they're also the exclusive
hydration partner to Team USA
weightlifting and relied on by tons of
Olympic athletes and everyday High
performers all around the world also
there is a nobs no questions asked
refund policy where you can buy a box
completely risk-free and if you do not
like it for any reason they will give
you a refund during an unlimited
duration and you don't even need to
return the box that's how confident they
are that you love it element a giv away
a free sample pack of all eight flavors
with your first box if you go to the
link in the description box below or
drink LM nt.com
MW that's drink LM nt.com
MW what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to
subscribe